this is the story of a plant
but not just any plant it is the story
of a plant that long long ago once ruled
the world
a plant that today
is the very last of its kind
it's this plant behind me encephalitis
woody eye e woody eye for short and i've
been looking after it for over 20 years
it was named for british botanist john
medley wood who in 1895 discovered it
growing on a hillside on the coast of
south africa the strange handsome plant
caught his eye and he carefully removed
a small portion of it and had it shipped
all the way to london to hear kew
gardens where it's been for the last 117
years but its history goes much
much
further back
you see encephalitis woody eye is what
is known as a cycad
and sonic heads have been around for 300
million years as the millennium rolled
on cycads flourished providing shade for
triceratops a perch for pterodactyls and
a tasty snack for brontosauruses
at one point during the jurassic cycads
made up 20
of all the plants on earth and covered
every corner of the globe
but
the good times couldn't last forever
the dinosaurs went extinct
ice ages came and went
new modern plants like conifers and
fruit trees started pushing cycads out
and the once proud population of e
e-woody eyes were reduced and reduced
and reduced
until there was possibly only one left
one single solitary e woody eye growing
quietly on a hillside which brings us
right back to john medley wood at the
time he had no way of knowing just how
rare his discovery was
but expedition after expedition in
search of more e woody eye have proved
fruitless you see cycads are dioecious
meaning you need separate male and
female plants to create a new one and
this one happens to be a male a true
lonely bachelor if a female mate cannot
be found it really will be the last of
its kind
[Music]
to this day researchers are still
looking after all
it's a big world
and might just be a chance
[Music]
in the meantime it'll have me to keep
him company
you